Montréal la multicolore la Métropole
s'est réveillée avec des élus de chacun
des quatre parties qui siègeront à
Québec comparé au monochrome bleu azur
sur presque toute la province L'Île
concentre les parties d'opposition
libéraux surtout dans l'Ouest solidaire
au centre et une touche de CAC et de PQ
dans l'Est je pense qu'elle est envoyé
un message comme quoi il souhaite que
tous
les parcs la voix de Montréalais à
l'Assemblée nationale
le Québec rural où à l'extérieur du
centre de Montréal et Montréal il y a
plus d'opinions il y a plus de avec plus
de communauté l'opposition il voit un
motif d'inquiétude il y a juste deux
élus CE 90 qui vient de Montréal donc
mon inquiétude elle vient de ce fait que
le nombre n'est pas présent on n'est pas
assez fort pour représenter Montréal le
Premier ministre a tenu à rassurer c'est
trop important Montréal notre métropole
entre autres au point de vue économique
et on va continuer de bien travailler
avec la mairesse puis trouver des façons
de de
se rapprocher de Montréal
les deux ce sera en plus de Chantal
rouleau aurait élu facilement dans
pointe au tremble l'ancienne coéquipière
de Denis Coderre Karine Boivin Roy a
gagné dans Anjou Louis Riel qui votait
libéral depuis un quart de siècle dans
la dernière composition du conseil des
ministres qui avait plus de la moitié
des ministres qui vivaient à Montréal
donc très conscients des enjeux des
préoccupations des Montréalais
montréalaise
pour porter la voix de Montréal il y a
aussi un atout supplémentaire au
lendemain de ces élections il y a aussi
trois chefs de parties qui sont des
députés de Montréal et vous savez un
député ne peut pas appeler le bureau du
premier ministre un chef de partie pour
peu et de plus en plus de Montréal et
voit la ville comme un autre levier de
pouvoir je pense qu'ils sont capables
les maires de ville depuis de grande
ville de pouvoir s'imposer problème dans
les villes c'est que leur seule source
de financement c'est les taxes foncières
on peut pas arriver avec ça ça peut
juste pas c'est d'ailleurs l'un des
sujets sur la table entre les villes et
Québec l'autre dossier chaud c'est le
pacte vert 10 milliards de dollars
réclamés sur cinq ans pour financer la
transition écologique ici Mathieu Prost
Radio-Canada Montréal